[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory
during his childhood a young Tom Riddle
visited an undisclosed Seaside location
with his orphanage and it was on this
trip that Tom discovered the infamous
cave a location that would play a large
role in his future as the Dark Lord
Voldemort you see Not only was the C a
place of Torment for Tom's fellow
classmates it was also the place that
housed one of his HW cruxes Salazar
sutherin locket an eerie sight met their
eyes they were standing on the edge of a
great Black Lake so vast that Harry
could not make out the distant banks in
a cavern so high that the ceiling too
was out of sight a misty greenish light
Shone far away in what looked like the
middle of the lake it was reflected in
the completely Still Water below the
greenish glow in the the light from the
two ones were the only things that broke
the otherwise velvety Blackness though
their Rays did not penetrate as far as
Harry would have expected the darkness
was somehow denser than normal darkness
and in order to ensure the secrecy and
protection of the cave Tom went to Great
Lengths first of all the cave was not
easily accessible requiring uncommon
mountaineering skills due to the cliffs
that prevented boats from approaching
and to deter unwanted visitors Tom
placed a series of enchantments on the
cave first of all he made it impossible
to apparate inside underestimating the
abilities of house elves who could still
bypass this
restriction next he constructed a small
entrance that required a blood sacrifice
to open as Voldemort wrongly believed
that physical pain weakened those
entering the chamber inside the Cave the
entrance was guarded by an infer
infested Lake an army of Undead soldiers
that would jump out of the water and
attack anyone who who attempted to
retrieve the guarded hwrs the hwr hidden
on an island in the middle of the lake
was further protected by a potion that
could not be touched vanished
transfigured or Charmed and the only way
to retrieve said hrug was to drink the
potion however consuming the potion
caused the Drinker to experience
nightmarish Visions intense burning and
dehydration and in case all of that
wasn't enough the darkness of the cave
was unlike regular darkness that it was
somehow denser even one lighting charms
like lumos provided limited
illumination and it's this vast Showcase
of intricate enchantments that truly
highlighted Voldemort's obsession with
secrecy as well as the importance of
keeping said cave hidden however despite
his very best efforts the cave was
eventually breached on several occasions
by regular black creature and lastly by
Harry and Dumbledore but my next
question is how on Earth did dumbledor
know where the cave was regulus and
creature knew where to find the cave
because regulus once served Voldemort
and creature served regulus but
Dumbledore didn't have anyone from
Voldemort's inner circle with info on
the cave so just how did he find it and
just how did he know to bring Harry with
him how on Earth could he have known
that the cave would require multiple
Wizards Dumbledore's journey to unravel
the mystery began with a deep
exploration of Voldemort's haunted past
the Headmaster recognized that the Dark
Lord's turbulent upbringing as an orphan
held potential Clues to his hiding
places Mrs Cole a caretaker at the
orphanage recounted the existence of a
Seaside location that the orphans
frequented during their summer vacations
but I'm jiggered if I know how he got up
there to do it all I know is he and
Billy had argued the day before and then
Mrs Cole took another Swig of Jin
slopping a little over her chin this
time on the Summer Outing we take them
out you know once a year here to the
countryside or to the seaside well Amy
Benson and Dennis Bishop were never
quite right afterwards and all we ever
got out of them was that they'd gone
into a cave with Tom Riddle he swore
they'd just gone exploring but something
happened in there I'm sure of it and
well there have been a lot of things
funny things she looked at Dumbledore
again and though her cheeks were flushed
her gaze was steady and Dumbledore
references it shortly after the little
stories of the strangled rabbit and the
young boy and girl he lured into a cave
were most suggestive I can make them
hurt if I want to in Half Blood prins
Dumbledore dedicated a significant
amount of time searching for Haw rxes
and it was his knowledge of Tom Riddle's
affinity for terrorizing others in sea
caves that provided him with an
essential clue to investigate similar
areas after an exhaustive search he
finally discovered the proper cave lumus
said Dumbledore as he reached the
boulder closest to the Cliff face a
thousand Flex of Golden Light sparkled
upon the dark surface of the water a few
feet below where he crouched the black
wall of rock beside him was illuminated
too you see said Dumbledore quietly
holding his wand a little higher Harry
saw a fisure in the cliff into which
Dark Water was swirling this is the
moment when Dumbledore and Harry
stumbled upon the sea cave sensing the
presence of magic Dumbledore deduces
that Tom Riddle had previously visited
this very cave how did you know that was
there har asked in astonishment magic
always leaves traces said Dumbledore as
the boat hit the bank with a gentle bump
sometimes very distinctive tracers I
taught Tom Riddle I know his style okay
so now we know how Dumbledore managed to
find the cave but my next question is
how did he know to bring Harry with him
Dumbledore was looking for Voldemort HW
cers all throughout Harry's 6th year but
he didn't take Harry on any other
occasion why the cave did he know that
there was a need for more than one
wizard in the cave or was it just
because Dumbledore knew he had very
little time left and wanted to give
Harry some experience hunting HW ruxers
well there are actually multiple
explanations first of all Dumbledore
likely foresaw Harry's usefulness in
reaching the HW Crux like Dumbledore
mentioned earlier he taught Tom Riddle
and knew his style because of this he
predicted that Voldemort would have put
traps to prevent a single person acting
alone from reaching the HW Crux next
Dumbledore likely felt that this was an
important opportunity to give Harry more
experience in dealing with HW cruxes
prior to the cave Harry only had
experience with one of the Haw rugs the
diary by retrieving and possibly
destroying another Dumbledore hoped that
Harry would feel more confident in
finding Voldemort's other HW cruxes we
see that Harry is exhilarated from
retrieving the locked HW Crux we did it
Professor Harry whispered with
difficulty he suddenly realized that he
had a searing stitch in his chest we did
it we got the HW Crux prior to the
destruction of this HW Crux things did
seem a little Bleak and this opportunity
would have shown Harry that Voldemort
isn't Unstoppable and last but not least
Harry himself asked if he could tag
along and if you do said Harry quickly
can I come with you and help get rid of
it dumore looked at Harry very intently
for a moment before saying yes I think
so I can said Harry thoroughly taken a
back oh yes said Dumbledore smiling
slightly I think you have earned that
right and from that exchange we can see
that Dumbledore agreed to bring him to
the cave in this same chapter Harry has
shown Dumbledore slug Horn's real memory
allowing Dumbledore to confirm the
number of Haw rers Voldemort has because
of this Harry had truly earned the right
to hunt Haw ruxers with Dumbledore and
the only reason Harry wasn't present
when Dumbledore went off to find
marola's ring is that he didn't have the
opportunity to ask beforehand though I
suspected Harry's presence would would
have been just as valuable there as it
could have swayed Dumbledore's
temptation to put the ring on his finger
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out extra content on my
second Channel harryt Theory extra as
well as all of the audio content
available on Spotify until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and to forget to
live